Stephen twitch bosses shattered Dancing
with the Stars TV family is opening up
to us after his tragic death welcome to
Entertainment Tonight as heartbroken
broken colleagues and Friends search for
answers to this shocking loss we have
news on the final message he left behind
E.T has learned twitch did leave a
suicide note indicating he couldn't go
on it was found inside the motel room
where the 40-year-old passed away from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound to the head
oh blesses are I have the sweetest
husband in the entire world
as for the family he leaves behind a
source tells E.T wife Allison has been
surrounded by family and friends and is
quote trying to cope as best she can for
their kids our source adds twitch's
suicide had nothing to do with finances
today E.T was with twitch and Allison's
tight-knit dancing Community who were
also grieving his loss as friends of his
how are you guys holding up
[Music]
wait holding up I've been an advocate
for mental health for a long time I've
had my own Journey with it I think many
of us have but to know that
someone that you would never ever expect
you would never have imagined new mom
Sharna Burgess has been open about her
struggles with postpartum depression
after the birth of her son with Brian
Austin Green Zane I'm hoping that it can
be used as a reminder to people that um
you never know life is precious and
continue to reach out to the people that
you love the couple has partnered with
movember for their hope for the holidays
campaign in an effort to reduce the
stigma of mental illness it seems I
think unfortunately suicide
feels reasonable for a lot of people
because they don't have places to go
that can help them realize that your
feelings are just that their feelings I
know personally I really want to send a
lot of love and light to his wife
Allison who I've known since I was a
teenager I just thought he was an angel
I really did and I said that to Brett
like I just couldn't believe something
like this had happened to somebody who
was just so good and so pure during
rehearsals for the Dancing with the
Stars tour we also spoke to last season
So You Think You Can Dance winner and
twitch's former student Alexis War he
was my judge when I did so you think he
can dance and he's like
the reason we stayed sane in a way
Alexis you talked about having problems
with confidence you shouldn't question
yourself he was like a proud dad to us
during our final interview with Twitch
in June he explained how the show shaped
his life not only has it put me on a
great career path but I also met my wife
on this show you know expanded our
family while I've been on the shoulders
but I mean it's been you know hands down
a life-changing experience
[Music]